Narendra Modi is a big
[Music]
[Applause]
video here I support the Muslim women
students will not be allowed to wear the
hijab
Community they wear their turban all
over from what you've seen from the
Muslim Community so far in terms of the
protests Etc
it's been peaceful yeah India's judges
are also highly islamophobic now many
many of them
the police in India are historically
anti-people as a Hindu here who's coming
on to go ahead and create Awareness on
this great Injustice that's going on
we need to do this for the future of our
children the future of our great country
the future of mankind this is your
brother and I've got a very important
message alhamdulillah our brother Eddie
is setting up the dean Center not just
the dean show but the dean Center a full
dawa Academy a Masjid a dawa Center in
America the first of its type the a
groundbreaking project and I want
everybody as I'm supporting it I want
everybody to support it so we can take
the dawah to the next level we need the
dean Center please support it
[Music]
greetings of Peace welcome to the dean
show and I'm here with the advocacy
director M James how are you thank you
how are you doing I've been here you say
assalamualaikum but you're not uh Muslim
you're him yes
a greeting for everybody Muslims and
non-muslims yes absolutely it's amazing
now you are one of the few people I
really want to commend you because you
are coming out even though you're a
Hindu you're seeing the injustices that
are happening and you're speaking out
against him
yes yes that's true so I want to commend
you for that and I want to ask you in
the recent years why are we seeing such
a rise in violence and bigotry against
Muslims in India
right so let me first uh just say to you
that being a Hindu it is my duty being a
Hindu to fight for justice and against
Injustice against all people everywhere
that is in fact also the message of the
Holy Quran that is the message of
prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him
Prophet Muhammad always said you have to
fight against Injustice no matter who it
is for no matter who where in which part
of the world he did not say you only
fight for Injustice you only fight for
justice and against Injustice for
Muslims he said you fight for justice
for all people
what's happening in India is very
unfortunate I am an Indian I am Hindu I
come from India and for all my life
since I was born and raised we did not
see or experience any discrimination yes
there were a structural discriminations
of course against people because it's a
work in progress that Society he has
many many fault lines but the kind of
attacks on Muslims that we have
witnessed in the last eight years and I
say eight years because it was eight
years ago in the month of May 2014 that
India's current prime minister Narendra
Modi he came to power Narendra Modi is a
bigot he is a Hindu supremacist
he is an Islam of foe he is a hater of
Muslims he has somebody who has presided
presided over a massacre of Muslims
Narendra Modi belongs to a party called
the bharati and janatha party that
translates as Indian people's party
there is nothing Indian about it it is a
wild party it is a vicious party with a
horrible horrible ideology driving it
because the BJP is an offshoot of a much
larger organization that organization is
called the rashtriya swayam sevak sangh
that's a mouthful it's the the original
is an Indian language it translates as
National volunteer core the RSS as it is
more popularly known was founded in 1925
so it's about to complete 97 years on
just one ideology and that is the
ideology of Hindu supremacism the
ideology of Hindu supremacism or it is
also known as
is very explicit and it says India
belongs only to the Hindus non-hindus
such as Muslims and Christians are
foreigners they are aliens they do not
belong to India India should be run only
by the Hindus for the Hindus and Muslims
and Christians should not have even
should not have fundamental rights
should be treated worse than
second-class citizens that is the
ideology of the RSS the RSS is the
ideological parent of the BJP the BJP is
in power in Parliament in India which
brought mandarendra Modi into power as
prime minister and that is why this
ideological movement this political
party being in power in India it has
been driving the violence against
Muslims all across India leading to mob
lynchings of Muslims leading to
demolitions of Muslim homes and
businesses leading to acts of vandalism
and desecration and demolition of Muslim
places of worship such as mosques as as
well as
all of that is being done and now they
are trying to get Muslims uh deny
Muslims their citizenship by bringing a
new citizenship law that is what is
happening in India you said Muslims and
Christians yes so why do you see a lot
of Christians here from America a lot of
politicians they're Christian why are
they supporting such a movement that is
against them and why do you also have
many countries even you've seen some
Muslim countries giving awards to this
individual well it is so confusing yeah
absolutely I agree with you brother and
it is this this is the problem with
foreign policy for most countries you
can accuse the American foreign policy
of many things but you can't accuse it
of being long-sighted of being of being
you know on the right side of Human
Rights the problem is that most
countries cannot see beyond their noses
now that is a critical flaw in the
formulation of foreign policy the United
States of America and of course
organizations such as mine the Indian
American Muslim Council and most other
organizations we work with we have been
battering the American system the policy
making Universe to do the right thing
and to call out bigotry and hatred in
India and to call out the Indian
government's failure to control that
bigotry and hatred and indeed we are
getting to some point where the U.S
government and its officials and
agencies have started talking about it
and going forward God willing we will
see more and more response but yes we
talk about Christians also because India
has more than 30 million Christians but
India has 200 million Muslims it is only
in a country the size of India which
with 1.4 billion people where that you
can see that you can say that a a group
of people who number 200 million is a
minority that's the Muslims so the a
foreign policy of all these Muslim
countries so-called Muslim countries
like Saudi Arabia which has given an
award to Modi or the UAE the United Arab
Emirates which are now in a partnership
with Modi all of these countries they do
not truly reflect the will of the people
there is no question that the people in
most of these countries are horrified at
the human rights violations not just
against Muslims but all people that are
being committed by the government of the
day well this is supposed to be the
biggest one of the biggest democracies
in the world it is the largest democracy
in the world okay then they have a
police force oh my goodness why is the
police force not stopping the lynchings
not stopping the brutality that's
happening against the innocent Muslim
population great question absolutely
great question brother I thank you for
asking me that question the police in
India are historically anti-people the
modern police in India they were
constituted by the British when they
ruled India for more than 100 years of
almost 200 years and they left only in
1947. the police were deployed by the
British to suppress and crush the
opposition to British colonial rule so
the Indian police are fundamentally
anti-people they are designed to be
anti-people and anti-democratic not very
different from the police and most
Colonial countries you go to Egypt I was
there in 2011 in Egypt during the Arab
Spring I was at maidan at harid and I
went to the police stations I spoke to
local people and they said the police is
the most brutal tool of Oppression
against us so in all these countries you
go to Pakistan Bangladesh India
Indonesia Egypt most of these Colonial
former colonies of the British Empire
the police you will find are the most
oppressive elements of the of the
administrations the same is true Plus in
addition to that the police in India are
heavily dominated by the Hindus not just
any Hindus but upper caste Hindus Hindus
that are brahmanas that are takos that
are I don't know about Banias but
definitely brahmanas and Tacos now those
upper caste Hindus in the Indian police
they are not just anti-muslim they're
anti-lower castes also that is why you
find you will be horrified to know that
the average custodial killings in Indian
police stations and and prisons numbers
between 8 and 10 a day so you have I
mean a day yes sir a day you have more
than 3 500 custodial and these are the
ones that are recorded right more than
3500 custodial killings a year in India
I mean just this Century we have seen
more than 70 000 people who have died 60
to 70 000 people who have died in
custodial killings now they're they're
virulently anti-muslim they are
islamophobic and therefore and on the
other hand the Muslims of India have
very little representation not just in
the police but in the entire Criminal
Justice System although the police the
Muslims are more more than 12 percent in
India's population they are hardly one
or two percent in India's Judiciary you
will find hardly one or two percent of
judges in India and Muslims likewise for
for lawyers and project government
prosecutors there's likewise for the
police likewise for administrators so
the Muslims in India are truly are
dispossessed and a disenfranchised
minority
they are large they are 200 million and
yet they do not have representation and
now because of the politics of the BJP
and the way that this this party has
come up this is in fact Mr Modi the
prime minister's government today in
India is the first government since
India became independent 75 years ago
that does not have a single Muslim as a
lawmaker that knows does not have a
single Muslim as a minister that is why
the Muslims are facing the brunt of
Oppression and violence violations of
human rights from the government as much
as from the non-state actors and there
is nothing that anybody can do about is
it a fair assessment and that leads into
my next question how strong is the Hindu
nationalism extremism here in America
but is it a fair assessment if we call
it because for the for the Layman to
understand when you say KKK
this being synonymous with the KKK
movement or even more extreme yes so the
KKK War caps right
the Hindu nationalists in America do not
wear capes so let me just clarify at the
very beginning uh Hindu Americans are a
model immigrant community
many many many of them are great people
they are the true
um they are true Democrats they live in
America they have integrated themselves
in the American society in a great way
they they are loyalists they're great
Patriots they're great citizens they
they are doctors they are Engineers they
are businessmen they hold High positions
as we all know companies like Google
Microsoft are run by Indian origin
people
at the same time there is a minority of
Hindu Americans in America who adhere to
this ideology of Hindu nationalism just
a few months ago
a leading Hindu a leading Indian
American activist named ten morrisonda
Rajan was invited by Google to do a
speech on caste-based discrimination
tenbury sundarajan is a dalit the dalit
caste is a former Untouchable cast the
most unfortunate aspect of Hindu Society
is that it is vertically divided in
different castes and and this is unique
to the Indian Indian Hindu Society so
there are lower the top castes are
called brahmins and the lowest casts are
called dalits and there was a time in
India and there still are some people in
India who do not even like to be touched
by a dalid there are cases in which a
dalit man marries a Brahman woman and
the dalit man is killed is murdered yes
they are called Untouchables they were
called Untouchables right and it is
against the law in India to discriminate
against the dalit people now then is a
is a fiery activist she is amazing woman
an amazing activist she lives in the
United States and she was invited to
speak at Google more than 3 000 people
in Google wrote to Google Executives
good leadership and said we don't want
her to speak
now it is suspected that many of these
three thousand people are upper caste
Hindus working in Google
so and then there are organizations
Hindus speaking up against this Hindu
she is not Hindu she's dalit she's
dullid yes because she does not consider
herself Hindu because they discriminate
against her but the Hindus consider the
that it's to be part of Hinduism it's
complicated brother all right but let me
come back to the point the point is
there are organizations such as the
Hindu swayam sevak sangh HSS which are
the mirror image of the RSS there's an
organization called the Vish Hindu
parishad of America which basically
translates as World Hindu Council of
America which has the same name as the
vishwendu parishad of India which is
Walled into Council you look at them you
look at their activities you look at
their ideologies they seem absolutely to
be joined at the hip then there is Hindu
American Foundation which has recently
filed lawsuits against so many people
because they barely said well these
Hindu organizations are connected with
the Hindu government Hindu organizations
in India and it bristled at the idea and
filed defamation lawsuits but if you
look at the politics of Hindu American
Foundation they're completely in sync
with with the oppression of Muslims back
in India so and then there is there is
an organization that calls itself
overseas Friends of the BJP of BJP now
BJP is the is the acronym for the ruling
party of India the BJP now this one
calls itself overseas trends of the BJP
it's been in existence for more than 20
years and in 2020 election cycle it just
rushed to register itself as a foreign
agent so what does it mean it leads us
to suspect that it is actually getting
money from India otherwise why would you
register yourself as a foreign agent in
America this is called overseas Friends
of the BJP now when you have all these
organizations in America you know
clearly that they are up to mischief and
that Mischief is Hindu nationalism now
that this these people they go around
the country trying to influence uh the
Interfaith Community the school boards
the police departments the the city
councils the Mayors the the house of
delegates in various states and
legislatures the state Governors and of
course U.S lawmakers they try and
influence all of them and say hey do not
go against India do not speak on human
rights violations in India do not speak
about do not take any action on the
minority on violations of minority
rights in India that a bulk of these
people these organizations they do that
and that is why we consider them to be
fairly strong but brother we are what we
know in our hearts is history is on our
side
the whole idea that repression bigotry
discrimination has no future in a world
that is increasingly liberal that is
increasingly Progressive that is
increasingly pluralist we are confident
that these organizations will bite the
dust in the United States of America
their ideologies will bite the dust in
the United States of America and we will
succeed in ensuring that the flag of
pluralism keeps on flying high but in
order to do that we have to fight the
good fight and continue doing I want to
get your reaction to this video here I
support the killing of the Muslims and
the Sikhs in the Republic of India
because they deserve to die terrible
filmed I believe in Canada I don't know
if you know this individual no I don't
openly advocating to imagine kill uh
Muslim not just Muslims but though
confused as Muslims seeks imagine yeah
this is islamophobia
this is pure islamophobia now this
unfortunately is so this is just an
example if I can imagine if someone's
brave enough to do that here what are
they doing over there where they have
the backing of the police and the
military and the government
right right so yes so we just saw a an
affidavit has been submitted by a by an
individual in an Indian Court just three
days ago who is a former member of the
RSS the paramilitary Hindu nationalist
movement and he has gone on record in a
court to say that the RSS is involved in
bombings across India which is then
blamed on Muslims and they are arrested
and that they are sent away to prison
for years upon years so the RSS the the
ideological organ parent of the BJP the
ideological order found of the these
Hindu organizations in America such as
the HSS the Hindu American Foundation
the
um
Seva International the bunch of these
organizations the vishwendu parishad of
America it's fundamentally a Nazi Empire
inspired a fascist organization which
has been involved in violence for
decades
and that is the truth so it's a violent
ideology and they are exporting violence
of language violence indeed all around
the world uh tell us before we conclude
we saw recently not too long ago on what
happened with the case where you had the
Muslim women students who are being
discriminated against their hijab what's
the latest with that yes so the latest
with that is that India's Supreme Court
has listed that case for a hearing now
this happened in the month of January in
a state called Karnataka it is in the
south of India that state is ruled by
the BJP which is the party of India's
Prime Minister Modi I talked about uh
substantially I talked about this
political party this is a hardcore
islamophobic anti-muslim party it's a
and because there have no this is
something very important to understand
the various state governments run by the
BJP and the federal government of Prime
Minister Modi have been hugely
inefficient they have failed at
governance over the years
India has been sinking into poverty more
and more hundreds of millions of people
are more and more sunk into poverty now
than they were before Mr Modi came to
power but to hide their failures of
governance they keep on harping on the
anti-muslim policies that's what they do
so this happened in the state of
Karnataka where the state government out
of the blue for no reason absolutely
it's it's it sent out it created a new
law saying Muslim women students will
not be allowed to wear the hijab now
that has become
thousands of Muslim girls have lost
their year they could not even take the
exams because of it they went to the
state High Court uh
the state High Court did not accept that
petition because like I said India's
judges are also highly islamophobic now
many many of them and they are there
they're giving completely partisan
rulings it is laughable it's shocking
how the Indian Judiciary has collapsed
under the pressure of Hindu nationalism
it's completely unbelievable there was a
time not too long ago when by and large
the Indian Judiciary was considered
non-partisan it was considered in many
ways on par with Western democracies but
now the Indian Judiciary has completely
collapsed and on the on the weight of
Hindu nationalism so the high court in
Karnataka it ruled against the Muslim
women they immediately went to the
Supreme Court in the month of February
and the Supreme Court said oh there is
no rush to hear this case so as a result
thousands of Muslim girls and women have
lost their ear now the case has been
listed before The Supreme Court I can
only pray that the Supreme Court will do
the right thing follow the constitution
of India which is explicitly clear and
it says that no one shall be
discriminated against on the basis of
religion but you never know with what's
going to happen with the India yeah
that's a clear violation of something
that's just it's a violation of
international law it is a violation of
India's Constitution to deny Muslim
women from wearing their hijab to
schools and colleges or anywhere because
the Indian constitution discriminate
bars discrimination the Hindu Sikh
Community they wear their turban all
over in schools in colleges in their
jobs in the Army in the government
everywhere and they are not stopped I
want to commend you once again and would
you be willing to come back on if we
have someone from that party who wanted
to come on and go ahead I would love to
talk to them sit across the table and
talk with Hindu nationalist in America
all right I doubt though whether they
will join you well we try to keep it
open and fair and balanced so if there's
anybody from that party like to come on
The Dean show will bring our friend here
on let's get to the bottom of things
bring them on thank you very much thank
you brother so much thank you thank you
for your wonderful work and contribution
as a Hindu here who's coming on to go
ahead and create Awareness on this great
Injustice that's going on like I said it
is the duty of all right-minded Hindus
Muslims Christians jains Sikhs
zoroastrians Baha'is Buddhists it is
everybody's Duty including the duty of
people of non-faith no of no faith to
fight for justice for everybody
God bless you I cannot leave without
giving you a gift if you are not yet
Muslim and you tune in to see what these
Muslims are talking about and you like a
free copy of the Quran go and visit
thedineshow.com we'll take care of the
postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you this is
your brother Hamza Andreas and I want
every single one of you to support Eddie
from the dean show financially and
otherwise but in what way
I want you to support his new project
the dean Center is going to be a
transformative experience at the center
why because it's going to be a Masjid
it's going to be a place of worship it's
also going to have Fitness facilities
and it's also going to be a dollar
Center to call people back to Allah
Muslims and non-muslims and we trust
Eddie completely I for one will take a
thousand bullets for Eddie he has a
vision he has more than 15 years of
experience in the tower he's had a huge
success with the dean show and he has
the support of many Duart and preachers
and Scholars from all around the world
it's going to be an amazing project for
everybody go to the dean center.org
donate now
[Music]
hmm
[Music]